[Music]
my name is Alvin swalls honor of Lizzie
Pincus and olive
brother by brother Rover lives of Jewish
pastry made with a cream cheese and
butter dough raisin walnuts
well octomber cakes 1962 I came in in
Europe and I worked in you a hospital
peeling onions and they had a bakery
date so I went there to work through
time I went I went to school I learned a
lot of Jewish stuff popke Armitage I let
stuff like they make bacon is a dying
art yes
nobody's doing like thieves all the
Baker's like myself few of us left so I
love sweets so I'll just change anything
wrong I fix it - I like it
[Music]
please we make raspberry apricot
chocolate sometimes more thing you do
you to butter cream cheese vanilla
well summertime you keeping the
refrigerator because about a melting
today on table when - time is choice if
you have to take out of the fridge at
least half an hour 45 minutes roll it
out nothing big about 300 pieces - other
pieces not too thin because food from go
through make sure the flour on top folic
would you roll it it's flaky the raisin
we usually cook it so I can get nice and
plump
they say cast a weapon well I need a bit
give a flavour when we put on top its
moist
I keep the rubber moist inside why since
I'm flicking it outside sit and then you
roll it up
it's called process four or five other
things goes to inside you'll be better
than me
[Music]
spanning people like people all happy
but anybody not the rubble everybody in
the kids you have to go from the price
to Lee is sawed off 50 cents 70 cents 80
cents a dollar at all 25 last week we
just went up Saturday 150 do the hit but
everything send me know everything the
way for Dyson on auto-ship on the Danish
I love everything but take your period
it's not a boring job at all I'm rolling
dough had to spine surgeon buying it fun
stuff is good and I think you feel good
right
[Music]
you
[Music]